[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wenn es um die
Pflege geht sprechen wir ja häufig über
Krankenpflege Pflegeheime selten über
die ambulante Pflege dabei werden vier
von fünf Millionen Menschen tatsächlich
zu Hause versorgt viele gehen dabei an
ihre Grenzen auch an ihre finanziellen
so sehr sogar dass sie in Armut
abzurutschen drohen Verbesserungen
sollte das heute im Bundestag
verabschiedete Pflege unterstützungs-
und entlastungsgesetz bringen aber wenn
selbst der zuständige
Bundesgesundheitsminister einräumt dass
das kein perfektes Gesetz sei dann kann
man sich vorstellen was die Betroffenen
von diesem Wort Monster halten Frank
Buchwald
Christina Bauer hat die Probleme täglich
vor Augen sie arbeitet für einen
Pflegedienst aus großropperhausen im
Schwalm-Eder-Kreis viele Patienten weite
Wege wenig Geld denn bei der Pflege wird
seit Jahren gespart denn das ist für den
ein oder anderen mit Sicherheit schon
heftig oder die haben dann Leistungen
die
gekämmen oder so haben die dann halt
rausgeschrieben halt um irgendwo noch
ein paar Cent einsparen zu können das
Dilemma der Pflege kaputt gespart sagen
viele in Berlin das aber lässt der
Minister nicht gelten und kündigt vor
der Entscheidung zur Pflegereform schon
gleich die nächste an
[Applaus]
wir werden weitergehen in einem Jahr
werden wir die Basis der Finanzierung
der Pflegeversicherung verbreitern
darauf haben wir unseren anderen
Regierung geeinigt fünf Prozent mehr
Pflegegeld soll es nun geben weniger als
die Inflationsrate dafür steigen die
Beiträge um 0,35% vom Bruttolohn
kinderlose Zahlen 0,6% Punkte mehr wer
drei und mehr Kinder hat etwas weniger
der Linken aber reicht das alles nicht
sie nehmen dann mehr Geld von denjenigen
die in die Pflegekasse einzahlen das
sind bei dem gesetzlichen Pflegekassen
übrigens vornehmlich die geringen und
mittelverdienenden und die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner Einkommen aus mieten aus
Renditen und Spekulationen all das wird
nicht angetastet mehr Geld allein aber
löst die Probleme nicht kritisiert die
Union viele Familien sein mit der Pflege
ihrer Angehörigen überlastet von
zehn pflegt daheim gepflegt und dann
kommt es eben zu oft in unserem Land zur
Situation dass dann eben der Notarzt
gerufen wird aus Verzweiflung heraus
weil man nicht mehr weiß wie soll man
sich denn helfen deshalb enthält das
Gesetz nun auch ein sogenanntes
entlastungsbudget um eine Auszeit von
der Pflege zu bezahlen bekommen
pflegende Angehörige ab Juli 2025 eine
Summe von
3.539 € im Jahr Eltern Pflegebedürftiger
Kinder haben ab Januar Anspruch auf
3.386 Euro danach erhöht sich die Summe
auch für Sie auf das höhere Niveau
müssen oft
bei uns sind dadurch ganz besonders
belastet mehr Geld im System die
Probleme aber liegen oft viel tiefer
Pflegefachkräfte wie Christina Bauer
muss man erstmal finden ihr Chef bekommt
schon jetzt kaum noch neue Leute
die Geburten starten Jahrgänge werden
die nächsten zehn Jahren in den
Ruhestand gehen und hinten kommt kein
ausreichende Menge an Pflegefachkräften
hinterher die wir ausbilden können so
sollen in Zukunft immer weniger
Pflegekräfte in einer immer älteren
Gesellschaft immer mehr pflegebedürftige
Menschen versorgen wie das gelingen soll
weiß der Minister wohl auch nicht so
genau gut dass er wenigstens die nächste
Pflege Reform schon mal angekündigt hat
in Deutschland sind also knapp fünf
Millionen Menschen pflegebedürftig vier
Millionen von ihnen werden zu Hause
versorgt und für diese vier Millionen
und die die sie fliegen soll das
sogenannte Pflege Unterstützung und
entlastungsgesetz eine Verbesserung sein
tut es das ist es das wirklich dazu
Fragen jetzt an die Präsidentin des
Deutschen pflegerrates damit einen
schönen guten Abend Frau Vogler
schönen ist es denn ein guter Tag für
die Pflege und die die sie im Alltag
umsetzen
müssen wir eigentlich ist es ein genauso
ein Tag wie gestern es war und morgen
ist sein wird weil diese Entlastung von
der wir hier sprechen in dem Gesetz ist
am Ende wirklich tatsächlich keine
Entlastung die bei den pflegenden
Angehörigen und auch nicht in der
Profession Pflege ankommt die Erhöhung
kommen zu spät wir warten seit 2017 da
drauf die 5% sind klingen jetzt erstmal
viel bedeuten aber in der Umsetzung für
die pflegenden Angehörigen in der
höchsten Pflegestufe in einem höchsten
Pflegegrad in der Einstufung 40 € im
Monat das heißt in der Pflege im
Pflegegrad 5 ist jemand schweres
bettläger ich muss Inkontinenz versorgt
werden braucht eine Körper Unterstützung
und und und und was man dafür Material
braucht und unterstützungsmaterial da
sind 40 € in den letzten sieben Jahren
als Erhöhung viel zu wenig
dann bleiben wir mal bei den
finanziellen Unterstützungen die diese
neue Reform mit sich bringt das
entlastungsbudget also was man zum
Beispiel für die stationäre
Kurzzeitpflege dann jetzt benutzen kann
wird angehoben auf etwa 3.500 € im Jahr
löst denn das die eigentlichen Probleme
naja im Grunde wird es ja gar nicht
angehoben sondern es wird
zusammengeführt also es gibt die
Verhinderungspflege bzw die
Kurzzeitpflege wird zusammengeführt da
findet keiner Erhöhung statt es findet
Flexibilität statt also ich kann
zwischen zwei pflegerischen
sicherungsfinanzierungsangeboten wählen
das ist ein Vorteil ja das ist auch
schon lange gewünscht das ist gut dass
es kommt aber es ist keine Reform
sondern eigentlich ist es eine
Notwendigkeit sie finden natürlich gut
das was passiert aber eigentlich
passiert gar nichts habe ich sie da
jetzt richtig verstanden
genauso ist es weil das verpufft
natürlich die ambulanten Pflegedienste
haben natürlich auch massiv mehr
Kostensteigerungen und die 5% fangen
nicht mal die Inflationsraten auf die
nächste Erhöhung ist jetzt für 25
geplant dann für 28 wir bräuchten
eigentlich für die gesamte Finanzierung
eine Dynamisierung eine Anpassung an die
Inflationsrate und nicht in vier fünf
sechs jahresrückschritten sondern
jährlich das würde wirklich pflegende
Angehörige unterstützen sie haben es ja
schon gesagt 4 Millionen pflegende
Angehörige das ist ein riesen Bestand an
Menschen die pflegerische Versorgung
leisten die müssen viel stärker
unterstützt werden in Zukunft jetzt
haben sie gerade die Finanzierung
angesprochen finanziert wird es jetzt
also über eine Erhöhung der
Versicherungsbeiträge
da wir eine Alterung der Gesellschaft
und ja auch steigende Personalkosten
haben muss ja dann in Zukunft deutlich
mehr Geld in dieses System fließen woher
soll das denn eigentlich kommen
das kann ja tatsächlich nur aus der
Gesellschaft kommen und deswegen
brauchen wir hier unbedingt eine
Diskussion auch mit der Bevölkerung und
ich glaube auch und das haben wir auch
immer wieder es gibt ja auch
Untersuchungen dazu wenn die Menschen
wissen dass die Gelder die sie geben
auch wirklich für die sozialen Belange
eingesetzt werden und nicht zum Beispiel
durch Rendite Unternehmen oder durch
intransparente
Kostensituation abfließen aus dem System
sind die Menschen auch bereit
tatsächlich für Pflege aber auch für
Soziales Geld zu geben und wir müssen in
Deutschland über die Prioritäten der
Geldverteilung nachdenken jetzt geht es
bei der Reform mehr insgesamt eigentlich
um Unterstützung und Entlastung so heißt
ja auch das Gesetz laut einer Studie des
Sozialverbandes VdK haben über 90%
keinen Zugang zur Tagespflege über 60%
nicht mehr ein zu einem Pflegedienst
wird es denn da jetzt Verbesserungen
geben
hier gibt es überhaupt keine Veränderung
im Gegenteil wir haben den
pflegefachpersonenmangel in Deutschland
wir werden in momentan erleben wir die
Situation dass in den stationären
Bereichen und auch in der ambulanten
Versorgung immer mehr Kapazitäten
geschlossen werden weil keine
Pflegefachpersonen da sind mit anderen
Worten hier wird die Belastung noch sehr
viel größer werden und auch zu den zu
der Situation
viele rufen auch Pflegesachleistung zum
Beispiel gar nicht ab in der Versorgung
weil auch die Bürokratie sehr hoch der
Zugang ist hoch wenn die pflegende
Angehörige bin dann brauche ich leichte
Zugänge zu dem Geld schneller einfache
Dinge und darf nicht über bürok
Bürokratie hören kassenanträge
pflegeanträge stolpern sondern
eigentlich muss ich unterstützt werden
und die Menschen müssen zu mir kommen
und mich unterstützen als pflegende
Angehörige
es geht ja um würdevolle oder auch
wertschätzende Pflege da wollte das
Gesetz eigentlich ein bisschen
Verbesserungen bringen jetzt wenn ich
ihn so zuhöre hat man das Gefühl es tut
sich nicht besonders viel ist es denn
eher ein nicht wollen ein nicht können
oder sind die Umstände einfach so
wir versuchen jetzt in der größten Not
nach vielen vielen Jahren darauf
hinweisen dass wir in diese Not kommen
werden versuchen wir jetzt die Dinge zu
ändern und ich erlebe in der Politik
wirklich ein großes wollen auch mit den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor Ort auch
aus dem Bundesministerium eine großes
wollen der Veränderung aber für uns ist
es immer wieder die Frage warum so
langsam warum dich konsequenter und
warum nicht die großen Frage stellen
also steuerfinanziertes
Gesundheitssystem public health mehr
nach Deutschland bringen eine große
handlungskompetenzverteilung in die
Gesundheitsfachberufe hinein das alles
fehlt in der Diskussion momentan noch
Frau Vogler dann sage ich an dieser
Stelle vielen herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch heute sicherlich nicht das
letzte zu diesem Thema
vielen Dank
und das Gespräch haben wir vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet das Thema Pflege
ist ja eines der zentralen politischen
Aufgaben unserer Zeit ein anderes ist
die Energiewende zu ihr gehört dass viel
diskutierter heizungsgesetz und da mögen
die aktuellen Zahlen des politbarometers
insbesondere nach den lauten Debatten
der letzten Wochen den ein oder die
andere jetzt eventuell etwas Erstaunen
aber 56 Prozent fänden ist gut wenn neue
Heizungen ab 2024 zu zumindest 65% mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben würden
39% finden es nicht gut 5% sagen sie
wissen es nicht
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck hat ja heute
angekündigt das Gesetz an einigen
Stellen nachzubessern und nachbessern
ist ein gutes Stichwort denn das müsste
die Ampelkoalition was ihr Verhalten bzw
ihr Verhältnis untereinander anbelangt
insgesamt auch nur noch 16 Prozent
empfinden das Verhältnis zwischen SPD
grün und FDP als gut
75% als schlecht mehr Zahlen aus dem
aktuellen Politbarometer gibt es am Ende
der Sendung
ja also der Ton macht dann wohl doch die
Musik und wie frustriert selbst
Mitglieder der FDP und Grün über diesen
schrillen bis schiefen Ton sind darüber
haben wir hier gestern ausführlich
berichtet der Basis der SPD dürfte es da
nicht anders gehen erst recht nicht in
Berlin das hat aber noch ganz andere
Gründe das Rote Rathaus vor drei Monaten
bei der Landtagswahl deutlich verloren
die Mitglieder gespalten was die neue
schwarz-rote Koalition anbelangt und die
Parteispitze seitdem massiv unter Druck
der Landesparteitag heute sollte
Aussprache und Annäherung bringen Stefan
Merseburger
Lächeln immer schön lächeln auch wenn
von vornherein schon feststeht das ist
unangenehm wird die Linken in der
Berliner SPD sind wütend 18,4 Prozent so
schlecht wie nie zuvor war das Ergebnis
bei der letzten
Abgeordnetenhauswahl Tag der Aussprache
heute brauchen Franziska Giffey und Reiz
Allee der in der Berliner SPD die
Strippen zieht nie mehr Qualitäten zum
Wahl Debakel kommt noch der Rechtsruck
die Koalition mit der CDU ich glaube
dass man mit der CDU nicht sofort bei
vielen in Berlin bewegen kann also
bezahlbares Wohnen gute Arbeit
Mindestlohn Tarif Treue all diese Themen
bezahlbare Bildung da ist die CDU jetzt
nicht vorne sondern das wären eher
progressivere Kräfte ich finde es immer
richtig progressive Mehrheiten wenn sie
da sind zu nutzen weil ich glaube dass
man da mehr im Sinne der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger machen kann mehr für soziale
Gerechtigkeit und außerdem hätte ich mir
eben gewünscht dass wir das Rote Rathaus
eben auch behalten Giffey hätte
Bürgermeisterin bleiben können auch für
Rot-Grün-Rot gab es eine Mehrheit doch
die CDU hatte satte 10% Vorsprung
dass wir
euch verlieren als eine Partei die am
Sessel im Roten Rathaus klebt in den
Wählern das Signal gibt uns doch egal
was ihr wählt wir machen einfach
trotzdem weiter macht Verlust bei
gleichzeitigem macht er halt
Opposition das findet auch Franziska
Giffey ist Mist
lag in der Berliner Luft
dahin deutlich wir haben es erlebt im
Parlament
wir mitbekommen haben es gab
Ängste und vertrauliche Gespräche dazu
die Jusos wir sind stickt das nicht
wirklich sie bringen einen Antrag ein
der fordert dass dem Landesvorstand der
Partei in Zukunft nicht weiter
mehrheitlich Regierungsmitglieder und
hohe Funktionsträger angehören sollen
Rat und Franziska ihr habt uns in diese
als Landesvorsitzenden diese Wahlen
geführt aus unserer Sicht habt ihr bis
heute noch nicht genug Verantwortung
dafür übernommen wie diese Wahlen
ausgegangen sind der Antrag wurde
angenommen ein klarer fingerzeigern die
Parteispitze die gelobt Besserung wir
werden für den Parteitag im Mai 2024 das
zweitens unsere Partei inhaltlich
strukturell und personell breiter
aufstellen ein ungemütlicher Parteitag
aber keine Generalabrechnung die
Parteispitze geschwächt und weiter im
Amt
und wir machen mit Nachrichten weiter
und die beginnen mit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine da melden die Ukraine und
Russland neue Angriffe der jeweils
gegnerischen Seite mit ihrer Flugabwehr
konnte die Ukraine dutzende russische
raketeneinschläge verhindern zugleich
gab es auf russischem Territorium wieder
Angriffe auf das Gebiet Belgrad in der
Ukraine wurden bei uns russischen
Attacken unter anderem auf eine Klinik
in Mikro zwei Zivilisten getötet
unterdessen haben Russland und die
Ukraine erneut Gefangene ausgetauscht
und 106 Ukraine sind zurück in ihrer
Heimat
um weitere Unterstützung für die Ukraine
geht es auch beim Besuch von
Bundeskanzler Scholz in Estland an den
Gesprächen in Tallinn nehmen die
Regierungsspitzen aller drei baltischen
Staaten teil auch die von Lettland und
Litauen alle drei Länder Grenzen an
Russland und fühlen sich wegen des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine bedroht so
wird auch über die militärische Stärkung
der nato-ostflanke beraten Scholz
bekräftigte die deutsche Bereitschaft
zur Verteidigung der baltischen
Nato-Partner im Falle eines Angriffs am
Frankfurter Flughafen hat Bundeskanzler
Scholz am Mittwochabend wie erst heute
bekannt wurde eine schwerwiegende
Sicherheitspanne erlebt ein Mann hatte
sich in seinem Pkw unbemerkt dem Konvoi
des Kanzlers angeschlossen und alle
Sicherheitssperren passiert auf dem
Rollfeld schüttelte der 48-Jährige dann
Scholz die Hand und umarmte den Kanzler
danach wurde er von der Bundespolizei
festgenommen ein Schnelltest weist auf
Drogeneinfluss hin weiteres wird geprüft
eine schnelle Einführung der
Kindergrundsicherung fordern die Jugend-
und Familienminister von Bund und
Ländern nur Bayern schloss sich nicht an
Fazit des Treffens in Potsdam mit der
Zusammenführung von Kindergeld und
Kinderzuschlag sollen Armut verringert
und alle Familien besser gestellt werden
ab 2025 soll es die Kindergrundsicherung
geben und das Familienministerin Paulus
meldete dafür einen Finanzbedarf von 12
Milliarden Euro an
gegen die Stimmen der Opposition hat der
Bundestag den mali-einsatz der
Bundeswehr ein letztes Mal verlängert
die rund 1.400 Soldaten werden somit
erst Ende Mai 2024 abgezogen die
Ampelkoalition begründet dies mit der
Absicherung der Präsidentschaftswahlen
im Februar auch der Bundeswehreinsatz im
Kosovo ist vom Bundestag um ein weiteres
Jahr verlängert worden ein Grund die
Spannungen im Land mit der serbischen
Minderheit rund 70 deutsche Soldaten
sollen weiterhelfen die Stabilität des
balkanstaates zu sichern
was ist los in Serbien das Land kommt
einfach nicht mehr zur Ruhe seit Anfang
des Monats innerhalb von zwei Tagen bei
zwei Amokläufen 18 Menschen starben
seitdem gehen immer wieder 10.000
Menschen auf die Straße sie wollen ihre
Anteilnahme zeigen aber sie wollen auch
dem Regime um Alexander Vucic etwas
anderes zeigen nämlich dass sie genug
haben von den Missständen insgesamt im
Land dem muss der Präsident dann
wiederum etwas entgegensetzen er lief
heute auf zur Zitat größten Demo aller
Zeiten Britta Hilpert
Bus Nummer 37 aus Leskovac ist einer von
sehr vielen die heute nach Belgrad
kommen sie bringen Teilnehmer der Demo
der Regierung es soll die größte aller
Zeiten werden manche meinen es wurde
nachgeholfen sagen sie die Leute mal wie
viel Geld sie bekommen 5000 Dinar habe
ich gehört
nicht unterstütze Alexander Vucic sagt
er dagegen wieso viele fast wortgleich
Präsident Vucic braucht dieses Bild
seine Anhänger füllen die Straßen denn
vor einer Woche waren es seine Gegner
zehntausende waren es mehr als je in
seiner Amtszeit ausgelöst durch die
Amokläufe vor drei Wochen
am 3 mai schoss ein 13-Jähriger in
Belgrad auf Schulkameraden zehn Tote
darunter neun Kinder kurz danach noch
ein Amoklauf acht weitere Tote die
Blumen am Tatort welken schon nicht aber
die Empörung was ich ändern muss die
ganze Regierung meint diese Mutter
alles in dieser Gesellschaft muss sich
ändern meinte er vor allem die
medienmaßnahmen sind bildträchtig aber
wenig wirksam Serbiens waffenkultur will
er eindämmen doch von bis zu 3 Millionen
illegalen Waffen wurden nur ein bis zwei
Prozent abgegeben die Balkan-Kriege
Hallen nach und wo sich selbst hält
Spannungen mit Nachbarn bewusst am
Kochen meint Sicherheitsexperte Petrovic
unsere Regierung nutzt die Angst als
machbar sie macht selbst Angst an unter
unseren Bürgern
dabei helfen Regierungs den Medien wie
Pink und happy TV sie unterstützen wocic
sie verbreiten nationalistische und
pro-russische Propaganda
ebenso wie Hass und Aggression in
menschenverachtenden Reality-Shows
aggressiv auch die Premierministerin
nennt sie die Opposition und dass die
regierungskritischen Demos ein Produkt
ausländischer Geheimdienste sein
es ist eine hier bekannte
regierungstaktik mit Fake News und Hass
abzulenken von internen Problemen das
stößt jetzt an Grenzen
es geht nicht mehr nur um Amokläufe sagt
Petrovic sondern eher darum dass dieses
Regime Werte pflegt wie der Demokratie
widersprechen
hat nun Zugeständnisse gemacht er will
sich vom Parteivorsitz zurückziehen eine
TV-Show wurde abgesetzt Minister
entlassen morgen bei der nächsten
anti-demo wird sich zeigen ob das
Serbien reicht
damit zur Wirtschaft beim elektrobauer
Tesla gibt es offenbar ein großes
Datenleck betroffen ist auch das Verb
Grünheide bei Berlin Gundula stimmt es
ja die Datenschutzbehörde Brandenburg
hat sich eingeschaltet 100 GB an
mutmaßlichen tesladaten von Kunden
Mitarbeitern und Projekten sind dem
Handelsblatt zugespielt worden Frank
Bethmann um welche tesla-daten geht es
da genau sind offenbar sehr sensible
Daten aus dem Konzern geflossen
Informationen zu Kunden und
Geschäftspartnern aber auch von über
mehr als 100.000 Beschäftigten wo Sie
wohnen was sie bei Tesla verdienen das
geht den bisherigen Angaben zur Folge
weit über das tesla-werk im
brandenburgischen Grünheide hinaus hier
aber soll das datenlack sein sollten
sich die Hinweise erhärten wäre es aus
datenschutzrechtlicher Sicht ein
besonders schwerwiegenderfall im weil
weltweit eine große Zahl an Personen
betroffen ist
und was bedeutet das grundsätzlich für
das datengesteuerte autonome fahren das
Tesla Yam maßgeblich vorantreibt ja das
ist die andere ganz große Sache da
sensible personenbezogene Daten an die
Öffentlichkeit geraten ist es eine fast
brisante aber ist das Tesla offenbar
große Probleme mit dem Thema Autopilot
hat die Tesla falls sollen tausende
Beschwerden über
Fahrassistenzsysteme enthalten Kunden
schildern wie ihre Autos plötzlich
liefern Geisterhand Bremsen oder abrupt
beschleunigen und es zu Unfällen kommt
er hört nicht nur die Börse auf wie groß
sind Teslas technische Probleme wirklich
ein funktionierender Autopilot
entscheidet darüber ob Tesla viel Geld
wert ist oder praktisch 0 das hat im
letzten Jahr kein geringer als der
Konzernchef selbst Elon Musk gesagt und
der will es wissen Frank bieten vielen
Dank
zum Sport bei der Tischtennis WM in
Südafrika sind alle deutschen Teilnehmer
ausgeschieden die Weltranglisten 10 ging
Hand die erste deutsche in einem
WM-Viertelfinale seit 24 Jahren unterlag
der chinesischen Weltranglisten ersten
Sonnenschein und im Herren Doppel
Halbfinale mussten sich Dimitri of und
Patrick Franziska der Konkurrenz aus
Südkorea geschlagen geben
mit großer Spannung geht die Bundesliga
morgen in den letzten Spieltag der
Saison die besten Chancen auf die
Meisterschaft hat Borussia Dortmund mit
einem Sieg gegen Mainz 05 würde der BVB
den Titel klar machen nach zehn Jahren
Bayern Dominanz die Mannschaft von
Thomas Tuchel muss also auf einen
Ausrutscher der Dortmunder hoffen und
selbst ihr Spiel in Köln gewinnen um
noch Meister zu werden der Titelkampf
später noch ausführlich ihm heute
journal Update um 0 Uhr 15
Spannung steigt das Update mit dir
später Gundula und wir sehen uns dann
hier morgen wieder morgen abend um 22:45
Uhr dann wissen wir wer die Schale
gewonnen hat zum 33 mal Bayern München
oder oder zum 9 mal der BVB hier geht es
jetzt auch weiter mit Zahlen und zwar im
Politbarometer mit Matthias Porno
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer eine Ampel ist ja
eigentlich etwas verlässliches rot-gelb
und grün Regeln geräuschlos den Verkehr
und verhindern dass es kracht das
politische Modell steht inzwischen fürs
Gegenteil die Berliner Ampel ist im
dauerstreitmodus doch so wie jetzt beim
heizungsdisput hat es im Bündnis von SPD
Grünen und FDP noch nicht gerumst wie
stehen die Deutschen zum hitzig
diskutierten Gebäude Energiegesetz
das Heizungen die ab 2024 neu eingebaut
werden zumindestens 65 Prozent mit
erneuerbaren Energien betrieben werden
sollen finden 56% gut 39 Prozent sind
dagegen
ob und wann das Gesetz durch den
Bundestag geht ist völlig offen heute
hat Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
versprochen seinen Entwurf verbessern zu
wollen beim Mega-Thema Klimaschutz ist
bei den Befragten durchaus Ungeduld zu
spüren
während Gott jeder Dritte findet das
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen bei uns zu schnell
umgesetzt werden meinen 42 Prozent das
ist zu langsam geht die jünger die
Befragten desto größer der Wunsch nach
mehr Tempo bei den 18 bis 34-Jährigen
kritisieren 60 Prozent das ist zu
langsam geht beim Klimaschutz
dass die Ampel oft schlecht voran kommt
liegt vor allem an der FDP findet etwa
jeder dritte 18 Prozent sehen die Schuld
bei den Grünen die wenigsten machen die
SPD dafür verantwortlich und gut ein
Drittel alle gleichermaßen
die Arbeit der Regierung bewerten 41
Prozent als eher gut mehr als jeder
zweite aber sagt sie arbeitet eher
schlecht und wenn CDU und CSU an der
Regierung wären nur 22% glauben dass die
es besser könnten 25 Prozent gehen sogar
davon aus dass es dann schlechter liefe
fast die Hälfte würde keinen Unterschied
erwarten
ein skeptischer Blick also auf die
etablierten Kräfte in Krisenzeiten davon
profitiert vor allem die AFD sie ist so
stark wie seit fast fünf Jahren nicht
mehr wenn am nächsten Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre könnte die SPD trotz
ampelzoff das zweite Mal in Folge
zulegen 20 Prozent plus eins
cdu/csu 28 minus 2 das zweite Mal
hintereinander schwächer die Grünen auch
weiter im Abwärtstrend 16 Prozent minus
1 die FDP unverändert 6 die AFD 17+2 die
Linke und verändert 5%
. die Ampel hätte damit weiterhin keine
Mehrheit reichen würde es für eine
Koalition aus cdu/csu und SPD sowie für
Jamaika also ein 3er Bündnis aus Union
Grünen und FDP
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
plus 5 bis -5 ist Sarah Wagenknecht
Schlusslicht
-1,4 etwas verschlechtert Vorletzter
Robert Habeck - 0,6 starke Verluste
Nancy fazer - 0,5 etwas besser Markus
Söder minus 0,4 davor Friedrich Merz -
0,3 etwas verbessert Karl Lauterbach
minus 0,1 Christian Lindner auch -0,1
beide verbessert auf dem dritten Platz
Annalena bärburg 0,0 etwas schlechter
Olaf Scholz zweiter 0,5 sehr viel besser
und deutlich von Boris Pistorius 2,0 mit
deutlichen Zugewinnen
seit Monaten schlagen Bürgermeister und
Landräte Alarm die hohe Zahl an
geflüchteten überfordere die Kommunen
vor allem fehle es an Wohnmöglichkeiten
Kita und Schulplätzen auch weil der Bund
zu wenig finanziell unterstütze ein
weiteres Thema mit sozialer und
politischer Sprengkraft
37 Prozent glauben dass die Integration
der Flüchtlinge in Deutschland gelingen
wird die Mehrheit geht nicht davon aus
am größten ist die Skepsis bei den
Anhängern der AFD am wenigsten Bedenken
haben die Anhänger der Grünen und Linken
zum Schluss ein Blick in die Türkei am
Sonntag kommt es zur Stichwahl zwischen
den an tierenden Präsidenten Rezept
Erdogan wieder gewählt wurde fanden das
nur sechs Prozent der Befragten in
Deutschland gut
81% nicht
exakt dasselbe Stimmungsbild also wie
vor drei Wochen vor dem ersten Wahlgang
in der Türkei ist die Stimmung ganz
anders Erdogans Chance auf einen Sieg
ist groß seine Kritiker müssen sich wohl
auf weitere fünf Jahre mit ihm als
Präsidenten einstellen
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
Zustandekommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
16 Juni hier folgt jetzt das Wetter
danach geht es weiter mit der heute show
viel Spaß dabei und einen schönen Abend
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend Vera heißt das Pfingst
Sonnenhof und das breitet sich bis
morgen Abend noch weiter aus es reicht
dann hier vom Baltikum bis zum Atlantik
die Thies müssen ausweichen das tun sie
über Nordeuropa über Island und
Skandinavien vor allen Dingen aber über
das Mittelmeer und so geht es dort über
das Pfingstwochenende weitere Unwetter
und bis zum Monatsende also bis Mittwoch
bis zum 31 Mai können da durchaus er
klägliche Regenmengen zusammenkommen 30
bis 120 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
sind da möglich aber auch hier am
norwegischen Gebirge wird es heftig
schütten die Nacht wird bei uns ruhig
allenfalls bildet sich etwas Nebel oder
dunsten es wird kalt hier im Sauerland
sind die Wette bis zwei Grad da kannst
also noch mal für Bodenfrost reichen
sonst gehen die Temperaturen auf 9 bis 4
Grad herunter und am innen und dann am
Oberrhein sind es um die 12 Grad
Höchsttemperatur morgen liegen bei 18
Grad an der Ostsee und 26 Grad am
Oberrhein nur in der Nordsee wird es
kühler dort gibt es nur 14 Grad dazu
strahlt die Sonne es gibt nur wenige
Wolkenfelder und das bedeutet auch eine
hohe Sonnenbrandgefahr bei uv-indizes
von 6 oder 7 droht empfindlichen
Personen ungeschützt in der Sonne
bereits nach 20 Minuten ein Sonnenbad
und außerdem sind morgen auch viele
Gräserpollen unterwegs in einer wirklich
hohen Konzentration so ähnlich geht es
weiter Gewitter gibt es allenfalls am
Alpenrand und wie sie hier im Trend für
Bremen sehen können wird sich an diesem
Wetter vorerst nur wenig ändern guten
Abend